[Music]
hey I'm Dale I'm an engineer that works
on AI on Google Cloud and I'm Tory I'm
also a developer on Google Cloud II I
thanks for coming to our talk so if you
work at Google being an AI or machine
learning is a really good field because
sometimes it seems like it's the thing
that everybody's talking about
everywhere when you say you work on ML
people think about the Google assistant
or way most self-driving cars or alphago
which was our algorithm that beat the
world champion at the board game go
but even besides these very high-profile
projects machine learning is in almost
every app on within Google from
translation to photos to Gmail and if
you just look at the number of internal
Google repositories that use machine
learning code over the past five years
it's absolutely skyrocketed
what about AIB on Google well for a long
time there's not as much machine
learning outside of Google because
machine learning is a complicated field
it often requires specialization and
possibly advanced degrees and frankly
there are few people with such specialty
but there are a lot of developers like
us not to mention there's the hardware
aspect and the DevOps component of it
even if you find all the right people
you have to worry about where to put
these compute intensive workloads by
Google we want to democratize machine
learning we don't want to gate keep
developers from using machine learning
and their application simply because
they don't have the training or the
machines to do this that's why the topic
today is machine learning without data
science expertise but first let's talk
about what machine learning actually is
the way that I like to think about it is
just finding patterns and data which
might sound pretty simple but you can
actually build lots of awesome
applications with that concept like for
example the algorithm that we recommend
zyou music based on your past listening
history or maybe you want to forecast
trends or build alphago a board game
playing
algorithm or maybe you want to do a task
called classification which also Kisan
because it's sort of the canonical
machine learning application
classification is essentially just
labeling things maybe you have pictures
of cats and dogs and you want to assign
them labels and the way that you
normally do this is roughly the same you
always build a model and that model
usually starts with a labeled training
data set so you'll have lots of pictures
of all sorts of different breeds of cats
and all sorts of different breeds of
dogs and you want to have as diverse a
data set as possible because the more
your model knows about the world the
more accurate it will be you feed this
into some machine learning algorithm and
out pops a model and if you've done a
good job and if you have a lot of data
hopefully when you show that model a new
picture of a dog it's able to correctly
label it as such
but if machine learning truly is as I
say finding patterns and data that means
you probably kind of need data well what
if you don't have data does that mean
you can't use the model well if you
don't have data you can Google heads
down your back you can use one of
Google's models here's a handful of
models here's a handful of api's that we
have that you can use I'm gonna quickly
talk about one or two of them and then
we'll jump into some examples and demos
so there's cloud speech to text speech
to text which is converting which is
converting speech audio into tax and
there's text to speech which does the
inverse converting text to audio and
then there's also cloud translation
which exposes which basically exposes
Google Translate as an API now let's
jump into a an example right away so
clout natural language what does it do
it allows you to analyze text so here we
have a couple news article titles and
you know we want to make some sense out
of it so let's hop into the demo we have
here we switch to oh there we go alright
so the first demo I'm going to show you
is actually the landing page of
the natural language API so there's a
bunch of content you can read but what
we're really interested in here is the
demo that's embedded in the web page
we've copied and pasted the news first
news article and let's click analyze to
see what we get and I'm not a robot
alright so it returns these information
by entities and you know there's some
like internet accounts it's they
consider it other Ennis models they
consider it consider that consume are
good and you know there's like four to
there's good considered numbers you can
take a look at sentiment so the
sentiment in this sentence is generally
pretty positive you can also take a look
at sent text if you want but what we're
really interested in today is the
categories so if you look at this it
kind of corresponds with computers and
electronics which makes sense can we get
back to this light duck alright so if we
look at the first news article computers
and electronics but if you pass the next
two articles into the demo I showed you
you'll get these two other categories
and all of this can be done using a HTTP
POST request which really simplifies
your life you don't have to go back to
this web page every time you want to get
information about your news article
titles and the same the similar route
you can use the similar REST API to
analyze images so here we have some
images about you know ice cream or dogs
if you were to let cloud vision analyze
these images it will tell you well
they're ice cream and dogs it's pretty
pretty cool the video intelligence API
is like the other API story mentioned
but it analyzes video so for example I
can track objects and put them in
bounding boxes it can transcribe any
text that was set in a video it can also
detect explicit content and to show you
an example of using this tool rather
than the curl request that Tory showed
you I'll show you how to do this in
JavaScript it's quite concise you
actually just call the video intelligent
client and then you upload your video to
the
Google cloud and you pass the video
intelligence client the link to that
video in the cloud then you'll also pass
it the features that you want to use so
in this case I'm like okay can you label
this video so tell me all the different
objects that you that you find and then
when the API returns it will give me
data in the form of oh there was a dog
that appeared between sex and seconds
three and five well rather than talk
about this let me just show you how you
can use it to build an app this one is a
shout-out to my colleague Zach thank you
for building this can we go to the
laptop please so here's our video
intelligence app and we use the the
video intelligence API to analyze all
sorts of data about videos so I'll tell
you what it does and then I'll show you
because of the audio so first we
transcribe the entire video and were
able also able to track objects in real
time so let me show you a demo of this
today we're at Starbucks with Google
made with code to teach girls how to
code in lovely emoji onto our hot
chocolate
[Music]
I'm dragging the emoji in to change my
perspective on code if you want to go
into computer science you be that person
to decide that
don't let anyone say no to you and
that's the video intelligence API let's
head back to the slides alright so we've
seen a bunch of off-the-shelf api's well
what about custom tasks let me explain
to you what I mean by custom task so
we've seen given a picture of a cat you
give it to the cloud vision API and you
get back this response that's really
great but what if given the same image
of a cat you want to give a mystery API
and you want to get back this result
Maine [ __ ] well this is specific to use
case this is not something the vision
API anticipated you might need so in
this case you're gonna need to train
your own machine learning model well it
turns out this is a fairly long process
approximately these number of steps
right I'll quickly walk through some of
these steps but don't worry if it's
complicated because it is alright so
first you have to gather and pre process
all these data and group it into these
different cat breeds and then you have
to split the data set up into a training
set and evaluation set and then you have
to build your tensor flow or Chara's
model you have to build the model and
then you have to train the model and
then you have to evaluate the model and
finally with the model you have to
deploy it somewhere maybe in the cloud
maybe on your phone just so you can get
to the final step of making a prediction
just so you can upload a photo into the
API and get the result you want let's
just say van [ __ ] right so in reality
you just want to get from step one to
step seven as fast as possible without
all of the intermediate steps well have
y'all seen this ad
if it's a chore right so you want to
make Google do it make Google built your
model for you
that's where cloud automail comes in
what does claudio mal claudio ml allows
you to bring your data and give it to
Auto ml Auto I'll take care of training
deploying and serving your model and all
you have to worry about is querying the
REST API and if we go back to the seven
step process I showed you it's really
simplifies the whole process you get
your problem you get your data and you
make a prediction all those intermediate
steps
claudio mel solve it for you today we're
gonna build our own custom auto male
model to do a task called object
detection that's one not only do we want
to know what's in a photo but we
actually want to know exactly where it
is we want to found find the bounding
box and today we're gonna build a model
that identifies clothing just like we've
done on sundar so how do we do it first
we need to find a label data set like
Tory mentioned and to do that we went to
kaggle which is a website for data
science competitions that also happens
to host lots of awesome free public data
sets and so we found almost exactly the
data set that we needed clothing item
detection so it had all pictures like
this and the human beings had labelled
pants shirt etc so this really helped us
get started but there was a problem
because these photos are a little bit
unnatural everybody's just standing on
this white background and so when we try
it on us and in real space the model
doesn't work as well so to fix this
problem we augmented our data set by
actually uploading our own photos and
outlining boxes of our clothing and we
did that for a while but then to make
the process even a faster we sent our
photos to Google's data labeling service
which is a feature that can have Google
annotate your data for you so to see
what this looks like you write a set of
instruction instructions in a PDF of how
you want your data to be labeled so
you'll say for example I'm gonna give
you all these photos put a box around my
jacket but if I'm wearing a shirt
underneath the jacket don't include that
so you send
your instructions to Raiders and the
results that you get back look something
like this I'm sorry I just dumped this
huge spreadsheet on you but basically
it's what we found in the photo and
where the box that surrounds it is
located now let me show you how we
actually go from that to building a
model let's hop to the laptop so here I
am in the auto ml vision UI now there
are two different types of models we
could train one says just labels a photo
cat or dog but object detection like I
was telling you about actually puts the
box around the items so our first step
is to upload our dataset which I kind of
showed you just to give you a closer
peek I'm gonna expedite that a little
bit so here are some of our data I'm
gonna hop into a photo of our colleague
page and if we wanted to label the
status at ourselves we actually just
click and drag around the thing we want
to label and then we say this is a top
and then we save it great now definitely
preparing your data set is the hardest
part of building a model with Auto ml
training is actually pretty simple we
just hop into the train tab we click
train new model and then we can select
different features like do we want a
more accurate model or a faster model
and then we click start training and
then we'll get a message that says
something to the tune of we're training
a model for you check back in four hours
and then in four hours you get an email
that says take a look at your model in
this evaluation tab we can see how well
the model did so most of the time it
will be better at detecting some
clothing items more than others so let's
just investigate how it did on t-shirts
now there are lots of statistics that
are useful to evaluate your model here
but I'll just show you the most useful
feature for debugging icing which is
seeing the examples your model labelled
correctly and incorrectly so these true
positives it correctly labeled as
t-shirts but here are some false
positives so I thought these were
t-shirts when they're not to be honest I
think it's kind of hard to tell the
difference between whatever but you know
this will help you debug your model and
see where you need more data and to
actually use that model you can test it
out within the UI so I'll just show you
uploading a mirror selfie of myself
that's me and there you go it's never
seen this photo before but it can kind
of guess her my jacket is and where my
jeans are now in addition to just trying
this out in the tool you can call this
model the same way we did the other
api's either through a rest a curl
request or in a number of client
libraries so Google handles all the
complications have actually hold hosting
your model in the cloud so let's hop
back onto the slides so what is actually
going on under the hood when Auto ml
builds that model for you now this talk
is machine learning without data science
expertise so this is unnecessary you can
cover your ears but in case you're just
curious to know what's going on under
the hood
well our photos are being classified
using something called a neural network
but the first step before we can feed
our data into an algorithm is that we
have to go from a photograph to numbers
so I suppose we have a photograph of a
cat well that photograph is actually
made up if it's digital of pixel values
red green blue which correspond to
numbers so using those pixel values we
can convert our photograph into data by
making it into three arrays of red green
and blue pixel values then that is the
input to this which is a diagram of a
neural network and admittedly I'm going
to sort of go over this very quickly
there are other great talks that talk
about it but basically what's happening
is those pixel values are being added
multiplied combined scaled and then
passed to a higher level level and has
passed to a higher layer and eventually
a number comes out that says 80% dog 20%
cat and at first the model doesn't know
how to combine those numbers
but as you show it more and more
training examples it becomes more
accurate if you're interested in this I
definitely encourage you to explore more
but normally training a model to do this
if you were to do it as Tory said from
scratch
takes a lot of data probably more data
than we had which was something like
under 200 examples but luckily when you
use auto ml you're not using just your
data you're actually using Google's
models that have been trained on lots
more data so you can have a very high
quality model even if you don't have
that much data to work with and these
neural network technologies power lots
of Google machine learning products like
a speech-to-text this transcription
translation and object recognition auto
ml also has lots of different data types
you can pass besides just images so
let's talk about that so yeah one of our
new products is all about tables it was
just freshly announced last month at
Google Cloud X and what does automo
tables do well it deals with structured
tabular data so let's let's just say
there's this table here and you have
strings timestamps numbers classes and
what you really want is just predicting
the target column so this is actually a
data set of a marketplace and you know
it's people people are selling things in
a marketplace we want to predict how
much those items are sold for well it
turns out there's a data science
competition for just this very specific
test I described and before I tell you
how Auto ml tables performed in that
competition
we actually graph the results of every
contestant on this visualization here on
the x-axis we have the ranking so the
more towards the right the better the
team did and then on the y-axis we have
the error so the people the closer to
the bottom of the chart the lower the
error so if you if you think about it
the better contestants have lower errors
which makes sense and the worst
contestants have hired errors and here's
how auto ml did in just an hour auto ml
tables is able to
past the median competitor and given
eleven more hours given twenty three
more hours Auto ml can do better and
what is interesting and something I want
to point out is that all three of these
one hour 12 hour 24 hours is on the
plateau which i think is where like the
data science enthusiast and data science
professionals hang out so that's really
cool for automotive or to be able to
achieve such results so Tory just told
you about tabular data but what about
text extremely common type of data for
that we can build a custom model using
auto mental natural language and there
are actually lots of different types of
natural language models that we can
build so we could build a classification
model so maybe we have US congressional
bills and maybe we want to categorize
them by what they're about we can build
a custom model to do that with Auto ml
natural language and then at next last
month we actually released two new types
of models that we can build the first
one is custom sentiment so maybe you
remember that Tory showed you that the
natural language API could take a
sentence and tell you whether it was
positive or negative but if you train
your own custom model then you can learn
very terminology specific things like
that waiting on the tarmac is bad but
having lots of leg room is great you can
also build a custom entity extraction
model so again out of the box the API
can take a string and tell you what
entities are for example it knows that I
am a person and a cappuccino is a
consumer good and it doesn't really know
what a croissant is but if I wanted to
make a model that really understood
foods I could do that and maybe say that
cappuccino is a beverage and identify
that croissant is a food and to do that
you create a data set much like the one
I showed you for object detection but to
do this you actually take strings of
text and you label them inline and you
say this is a food this is a beverage
and so on so let's review today we
showed you that if you don't have data
you can use one of Google Cloud e ai's
api's but if you have data and you have
your own custom use case
you can use clout Auto ml and we showed
you how to build custom models with
different data types here are some links
for you to visit we hope that what you
take away from this is that you can play
with machine learning while focusing on
building your app and not on building
your model because you can get started
with these tools really quickly probably
in under an hour and you can build
awesome things with them so thanks for
coming to listen we'll hang out here to
answer questions right now I guess thank
you all
[Music]